[Música]
[Aplausos]
el primer recuerdo que tengo sobre la
influencia positiva en el arte fue
cuando sólo tenía cuatro años empecé a
bailar ballet aunque era muy pequeño
para tener conciencia de lo que sucedía
mis alrededores el baile me hacía sentir
muy bien a los seis años inicié con la
poesía casi por error o por destino y el
lugar en donde los sentimientos se
expresan con palabras y poco a poco
entendí el poder de escribir para
superar cosas las cuales no estaban a mi
alcance
me liberan a ponerse se dirigen a una
vaca luis de first in america mes se
ubica malversado want my life
i
mind body and soul letras tristes en ese
nivel de facebook 17 6
es lo que yo pensaba que se lograría
cuando fuera adulta llegó mucho más
pronto mis poemas fueron publicados en
antologías y finalmente hace ocho meses
publiqué mi primer libro de poesías el
haberme involucrado en las artes me ha
brindado varios regalos marcando algo de
mí para candie's descubrí que no sólo
soy yo sino también colar el cura el
alma
las entidades en haití
en ese tema manifestó que después hay
nieve que va o al paso de los años
empezó a escribir máxima explosividad
sin creer que algún día pudiera publicar
mi primer libro de poesía sin dos de
tres años de experiencia
fue muy difícil pero nunca me rendí a
una vez quise rendirme por un golpe que
me dio la vida
la conversión de sangatesh la segunda
vísperas de nombres muy falta de
abonados en ambos aliados de los óptimos
de beagle fines de semana
los ejes de trabajo ha guardado un rail
de ver mejor verdad en el malbrán
sixtina de conexión
pueden imaginarse venirse a los eeuu con
muy pocas cosas yo vivía de una maleta
con poca ropa una mochila con sólo pocas
pares de zapatos y solo mi mamá tuve que
dejar a las personas y las cosas más
importantes de mi vida y tienen las que
cambiar a vivir en un suelo con un
sillón pequeño sino un instante
olvidarse de todos sus buenos momentos a
tener que vivir con miedo de hacer o
decir algo que molestará porque como no
era mi casa tenía que esforzarme y salir
adelante
y si la renovación en mayo un evento es
libre nivel el corner programa home
liberando en one step taste and
sometimes o menguante de bicis huelva
passionate y chino del suárez con el
world ganado de cantidad san diego de
aproximación de chats en vivo donde
fabrica en afecciones y tensión
espinales ya sea que mi propuesta es que
no solamente tengan un lugar para
acelerar el alma tener claridad de mente
y corazón para salir adelante
aquí es donde integramos las artes en la
armonía viene en anotar vocales quintín
y tú con jeans también pienso baby knows
i'm here we can help me que defensa
[Aplausos]
[Música]